dr asiem el difraoui ist experte für die
giz und politologe der
nichtregierungsorganisation candid
foundation schönen guten tag herr el
difraoui
beginnen wir mit dem heutigen urteil in
celle im wie alle medien schreiben
größten islamismus prozess der in
deutschland bisher gesehen hat was
bedeutet das ende dieses prozesses heute
aus ihrer sicht ja es kommt natürlich
sehr stark auf das urteil darauf an
würde er freigesprochen was wir wird
nicht mehr nicht hoffen wollen hat das
natürlich eine ganz schlimme
signalwirkung wird er verurteilt was
angst zu nehmen steht
irgendwas sind es war ein sehr
schwieriger prozess mit einer sehr
schwierigen beweislage gibt es natürlich
ein sehr positives signal haben dazu
sagen ist dieses urteil ist natürlich
auch so schwierig zu finden und der
prozess dauert auch so lange weil diese
dschihadistischen rattenfänger sich
natürlich sehr bewusst sind über die
schwächen und die gratwanderung die man
in unserem rechtsstaat rechtsstaat
unternehmen kann um halt eben nur schwer
verurteilt zu werden wenn sie zum
beispiel einen fall in london einen
london mensch der vielleicht noch viel
schlimmer gewütet hat als abu rahma der
mit weltweiten terror an verbindungen
da braucht sich die britische regierung
der britische geheimdienste die
britischen gerichte zehn jahre um ihn in
irgendeiner form was nachweisen zu
machen kann weil diese menschen sich
immer so am rande der legalität bewegen
und nicht offen zum mord aufrufen
sondern halt mit dem rechtsstaat spielen
ich habe davon dazu passende ich habe
vor jahren mit dem radikalen prediger
ibrahim abou nagie gesprochen den ja
viele kennen weil er kostenlos korane in
den deutschen fußgängerzonen verteilt
hat der hat mir damals klar gesagt der
koran steht über dem grundgesetz sind
das die rattenfänger ist dass die gefahr
von denen sie sprechen
damit fängt es an wenn wir jetzt
jemanden hat der koran steht über dem
grundgesetz das recht der menschen steht
unter dem recht gottes kann
das zunächst mal nur eine persönliche
meinung sein dh menschen können
friedlich das sind dann zu meister darf
ist in unserer gesellschaft leben und so
was denken sie wenn sie sowas in die tat
umsetzen hat unseren rechtsstaat nicht
mehr anerkennen dann haben wir ganz klar
den einstieg zum dschihadismus nach und
das ist genau diese grauzone wurst so
schwierig ist menschen etwas
nachzuweisen
wo man glaubt es gibt es ja auch zum
beispiel unter christen unter anderen
regierungen menschen die sich
zurückziehen und sagen wir ziehen uns
von diesem staat dieser
gesellschaftsordnung zurück aber die
nicht gewalttätig sind und bei den
salafisten ist es sowas gibt wirklich
eine friedliche aber das ist auch keine
strömung ich begrüßen kannst
anarchistische bewegung und es gibt
natürlich dann diese menschen da die
gewalt ideologie des salafismus
abdriften
aber ich habe noch eine kleine zusatz
bemerkung ich hatte für das beispiel aus
london genannt wo dieser ganz schlimmer
rattenfänger zu mehreren jahren haft
verurteilt wurde erst mit fußfesseln
wieder rauskommt aus dem gefängnis
irgendwann aber dann auch keine auflagen
mehr haben wird bewährungsauflagen und
das ist vielleicht auch die große
herausforderung avaya und seine
mitangeklagten werden aus den
gefängnissen wieder herauskommen
und genau wie bei den rückkehrern von
den gerade die rede war aus dem irak und
syrien müssen wir halt gucken dass die
menschen auch wenn sie dann wieder aus
dem gefängnis raus kommt entweder sich
in die gesellschaft reintegrieren oder
überhaupt mal integrieren oder halt
überwacht werden also bestehen von ganz
ganz großen herausforderungen auch wenn
obama heute heute heute verurteilt wird
in haft bleibt muss man ja dann auch
langfristig gucken was machen wir mit
diesen menschen damit sie diese
ideologie des terrors und des mordes
nicht nach haftentlassung und
langfristig weiter in unserer
gesellschaft verbreiten und unsere
gesellschaft ist schon viel zu tief
infiziert eben mit dieser
dschihadistischen gewalt ideologen das
wollte gerade frage hält
die frau die das eine ist hier sind ja
die die im zweifel wieder rauskommen aus
den gefängnissen dass die ebene
angesprochen haben das andere sind ja
die die noch nicht drin sind also das
bundeskriminalamt zählt aktuell 596 also
fast 600 sogenannte islamistische
gefährder wie groß ist denn aus ihrer
sicht die gefahr in deutschland in
europa durch radikale islamisten durch
dschihadisten erstmalig martinsmarkt
islamisten ja nicht so gerne das
vermischt dann immer realismus mit islam
und es gibt auch islamisten mit denen
wir zum beispiel arbeiten die sitzungen
der regierung von tunesien also ist das
wort dschihadismus berlin die gefahr von
denen die vom bundeskriminalamt und da
von den anderen sicherheitsdiensten in
deutschland irgendwie erkannt sind diese
bekannten gefährder
sie ist nicht geringer als die gefahr
von irgendwelchen jungen menschen die
eben halt nicht auf den radar in der
sicherheitsdienst ich erinnere ist hier
so an diese attentatswelle von vor
weihnachten schon november und oktober
geht ab und hatten von dresden am achten
tag von dieser schrecklichen enthauptung
eines schullehrer die stadt fahren nur
wenige kilometer und im ort wo ich mich
gerade in paris befindet wo meine kinder
zu stehen
das waren leute auf dem radar der
sicherheitsdienst aber der junge
tschetschenen zum beispiel der lehrer so
grausam enthauptet hat wahr haben sich
einst an keiner wusste erst geklärt war
da besteht natürlich die gefahr dass
diese menschen sich auch im internet wer
das geld zusammen vernetzen
irgendwann haben wir haben es mal
gesellschaftlich was wir machen da kommt
ja die frage auch nach der prävention
hier ins spiel was muss aus ihrer sicht
das ist ihnen ja persönlich auch immer
sehr sehr wichtig zu betonen was muss in
sachen prävention auch internationale
prävention aus ihrer sicht passieren wir
müssen natürlich ganz klar überall in
deutschland ziemlich weit vorne war
werden inzwischen über die biologie auf
er immer wieder bezogen dass das nichts
mit freiheit des clans
kaum noch irgendwas mit namen zu tun hat
das natürlich ganz große langfristige
aufgaben und ich haben also die angst
geteilt selbst von menschen die sich
darum kümmern dass wir zum beispiel
jetzt durch das ansteigen oder das
bewusstsein dass der rechtsextremismus
auch wieder so stark ist im tourismus
nach lessing
wir müssen gegen all diese bald
gleichzeitig gehen
das hat natürlich ihren politischen
finden und gleichzeitig ist es natürlich
auch materiell sehr aufwändig leute da
jetzt wie geht man mit den extrem ist
extremismus und wenn ich vorher
natürlich gerade ein rechtsextremismus
faktor koalition sind wie geht man mit
diesen extremismus gleichzeitig um
geschärft doch da asiem el difraoui
experte für die giz muss und politologe
der kenneth foundation vielen dank für
das tagesgespräch die leichten ton
aussitzer bitten wir zu entschuldigen
danke ihnen